this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
Columbia edu so you don't want to miss
this so please take your seats
you know today really represents an
opportunity for teachers college because
you have this last name alum University
oh we can use the word Bandini ourselves
as a community to the extent that we can
join hands with the faith-based
community and say that you know the work
of healing is so important that we have
to realize that we all have resources
and then we can do much more we doing in
partnership that's what today really
represents and so the highlight of today
X are we also joined the problem
hospital that provided that powerful
community health care for us so without
further ado what we want to do is to
urge that you sit down on the bed we
want to urge our team Austin is awesome
well see they're so excited
pass this book that they they're just in
another realm right now but I'm sure
that we start speaking they'll come to
attention the meekness levels understand
that are due to our Reverend dr. Carl
Washington Jr so I ask that you prepare
yourself to experience something that if
you don't go to church if you have an
experience of the kind of church that
new Mount Zion represents then strap
yourselves in and get ready to be
transported to a place that so many
heavy opportunity transported doing he's
got to stay in Club here okay so here we
go read come on you'll be impressed and
now let's give this to dr. Wallace and
all who are gathered here on this day to
share in this moment at this time as we
speak of issues that are crucial to our
community and to our world than those of
the Mel's line right here imagine all
white men came in second to recruit a
mighty way this morning's waiting to
bust the growth of one component that we
all need to be aware of and the
marvelous way that is clear so we could
right now
knocking the word rings out
gracious God our Father the name of
Jesus to say thank you for this day and
this
thank you Lord for dr. Wallace convening
this meeting so the wheel or might share
them how we act in what you really want
to be active in that is the two concerns
there were less this moment in Jesus
life because I'm a preacher we do have
to take thank you amen that was included
all they said the ones that were here
before me
amen god bless you meant balance as we
wrote this afternoon I was rich because
America sees of men but those was the
Christian faith mr. Hogg tomorrow for us
there is stuff to the gospel the first
that actually speaks to what we've been
talking about all day long in the 23rd
chapter 26 verse it says this and as
they led him away they may hold upon one
simon of serene coming out of the
country and on him they made the cross
that he might barely after jesus i will
talk the monster wouldn't mind on this
afternoon from this spot from SPECT
energy participant from stating to
participant i will post my might come to
many of these things that we see every
dialogue and post hoc over and over
again
about what
but most of us come as spectators that
we leave as spectators this is a shock
picture of a man taking one of the
greatest possible for anyone to take in
life he got down from the sidewalk into
the street he came from the side of the
road rate was really watching the proper
manner situation and became important
part of solution and vide was that they
had sat when he is watching the
situation but never really engaging in
becoming part of solution he stopped it
stopped being respected and became a
participant he got the health of the
grandstand into the arena that's that is
happening here this afternoon as we deal
with health disparities and hiv/aids and
all of the things of that activity it
was a strange and sudden experience
design it was in the congested colony
was a pilgrim from Africa coming to
Jerusalem for the Passover he was in a
new city just broken right standing
alongside he saw all his situation but a
common sight in the Roman world
so Peter sightseers and in the midst a
man carrying across too heavy plant the
man fell on the weight of the clothes
upon a Roman soldier grabbed Simon from
on the crowd and staying here get under
the cross side of the classroom I had
nothing to do with this I'm just about
stander I'm a stranger here yet they
grabbed him from the side of the rule
and
tell them to take part it was compulsion
of course nothing voluntary about this
he was great he was horrible front but
the spectator and foolish to be a
participant the leaves of the day work
moment of the Greek Coast in the simply
should be compelled to carry crosses one
the sinners the tragic history of
slavery and the group of human tears
even our nation one thinks of the
consciousness for armies an awful other
centuries one person's day brother saved
on the backs of people all over the
world poverty sickness famine and
disease that this text be stopped in to
our present day we need to lift the
burden off the backs of those compelled
by man who cares crisis but our theme
for the day is not concerned with those
that propelled to come across well the
goals we do it voluntarily those who are
gone and just watching - taking part and
because I can reject and I think
everybody can hear me I'm gonna project
because these microphones just aren't
working all right look here I've seen
for the day it's not concerned with
compare for but with folk who will
voluntarily do this work that our master
really wants us to do two men sat on the
bus one day in exchange for Milly
equestions these are questions that we
hear every day one ask whether you know
the other ass what do you do questions
we hear every day but what do you know
we came here today and we sat in this
room and in these courses and classes
and workshops all day long hearing what
people know the question is never just
what do we know the question has to
become what are we doing in our world
today we have overestimated the value of
hearing we all
beset by one of persistent delusions of
life the comfortable feeling which is a
constant boats jaw a complacency
we're always hearing but not many of us
are in the in the arena of doing and so
we come here today being spectators and
not participants many of us many of us
for this reason Paul in his letter
writes these words he says that we can't
just be hearers of the word we've got to
be doers also it is tremendously needed
in our religious life it cuts us at the
most important hearing down to its real
size here in y'all is just a small thing
it's what you do after you hear that
really matters sawing kirkegaard the
Danish theologian wrote one of his vivid
parables on the danger of becoming a
specialized hearer of religion and
occupation so absorbing that it left no
inclination to do anything about it he
imagined that near the cross of Christ
stood a man who beheld to see and then
became a professor of what he saw
thought of telling everybody about how
horrible it was he explained it to all
he came in contact with later he
witnessed the persecution and cruel
beating of the Apostles and became a
professor of what he had witnessed he
studied the drama of the cross but he
was never crucified with Christ in his
own life he studied at the salat history
but he was never lived and apostolic
life he was a hero not a doer that is
the sin y'all that so easily besets us
the church has become the modern hell
for the hurts and hangups
our society surrounded by heroes but few
doers many spectators but few
participants how do we get there
the church to move from being spectators
to participants all of us like great
Church
we love the gospel music we'll clap our
hands we'll jump around we'll singing
we'll shout and then walk right back
into the world that leads us and talk
about what we can do but never really
become doers how do you get there how do
we become the doers that we need to be
what I want to suggest to you here this
afternoon that the reason many of our
churches are not doing more in this
arena of life that relates to the ills
that pervade in our society is because
we don't have the concern of Christ in
our heart the parable of the Good
Samaritan you know that that man who
wasn't related to the fella who didn't
have any connection to the guy at all
with folks who were a part of his ethnic
group passed him by and goes to a part
of his local synagogue walked on the
other side of the road this man said I'm
gonna share with you what Christ is
really all about he says I'm gonna do a
costly act of love to let you know that
Jesus has no barriers when we take Jesus
off the backdrop of a finite knowledge
and hold him in the context of his
infinite love we will show concern for
our brothers and sisters instead of
being a community of condemnation we
will become a community of concern when
you think about how the HIV virus has
permeated our community and how even the
church has turned their back on it
because we have taken the world stigma
and placed it on individuals instead of
taking the love of God and sharing it in
our hearts when we take the command of
God to love your neighbor as you
they murder 2/3 full of you you all
about necessity we we understand who we
are we have to love our neighbor as well
as our God we must bring the best
thought we can summon it the fullest
knowledge he can acquire to the task of
determining what specific actions and
policies promise best to be the
environment of intelligent goodwill
towards men so the words become like the
little tent in the oriental fairy tale
made of a material so delicate that it
could be folded up and contained in the
palm of a man's hand
yet when unrolled it would afford
shelter to an army of thousands this
little tent love your neighbor applies
to the person who lives next door
but when unrolled by the consecrated
imagination covers the whole earth it
goes into the question of penology of
the social safeguarding of Hell of
international policies and after that
dedicated thinking come to dedicated
giving of the whole self it is not until
we become people who really understand
what the Word of God is really trying to
convey we got to have concern but it's
not just enough to have concerns because
concern people here but beyond a concern
we got to develop compassion too many of
us are spectators simply because we
don't have enough compassion it's not in
my family it's not touching my life and
so I don't need to show any compassion
on those in the Gospel of Matthew
there's a wonderful piece of Jesus by
the roadside watching the human family
walk by we read when he saw the crowd he
had compassion for them because they
were harassed and helpless like sheep
without a shepherd
his heart goes out and when it's hard
without his life father can I talk the
awful men how many times do we see Jesus
stopped and meeting the needs of people
he doesn't ask them where they came from
he never asked how they got the disease
he never asked how they ended up in that
situation he just stopped by and met the
need when are we going to step down out
of our safe protected positions and help
carry the cross when are we going to
echo the words of Jacob Marley and
Dickens A Christmas Carol mankind was my
business the common welfare was my
business charity mercy forbearance and
benevolence were my business went were
the church see the need to get down from
the sidewalk to the street when we begin
to understand that God has not called us
to be spectators on this stage called
life but to be active participate
it's a place in the Bible it says Jesus
goes down to a place called Sheep gate
there's some portraits there and there
people sick all in the Sheep gate and he
says to a man wilt thou be made whole
and many of us think that wholeness
deals only with the physical but
holiness goes deeper than the physical
because there's something folks who are
whole who are sick but there's still
hope
look we've got to have concern but we've
also got to have compassion but then the
church the church the church has to get
the commitment
look look today look today look today
look today around you and look at the
commitment of individuals and you will
discover we live in a world where
there's not a lot of commitment just a
lot of conversation we do a lot of
conversation but very little
little commitment to many of us
demonstrated indifference to the
individual has been they invaded by this
invasive virus as long as it does not
affect us let someone else deal with it
but God can't ends this but this shall
men know that you are my disciples if
you have love one for the other
see our indifference makes us bystanders
the reason we don't move like the
optimal and do what we ought to do is
because we're indifferent to the needs
and sufferings of others right now
everybody's concerned about the economic
crisis in our nation but can i really
help y'all here long before economic
crisis rounded the brains of individuals
there was some folks who had no
education at all who never worried about
an economic crisis because they said if
you got I got if you need I mean I
remember the day when I could go to my
neighbor and borrow a cup of sugar I
could go to my neighbor and give a piece
of bread because they understood in a
real way that if one of us was hungry
all of us were home and we got to
understand in a real way this day that
if one of us is sick then all of us are
sick commitment commitment in second
Corinthians 5:14 the writer says the
love of God constraineth us it makes us
move to action TR blubber
say it over 150 years ago that forwards
destroy slavery and none when the
Emancipation Proclamation for words he
said destroy slave it move people from
spectator to participate and these are
the four words for whom Christ died when
you look out over the community and
realize that no matter what
condition the person is there no matter
what relationship they might have they
are still folks for whom Christ died I
hope y'all the day is the most same four
words the church has to understand that
everybody is for whom Christ died huh
well someday someday these words will
destroy war racial discrimination sexism
discrimination exploitation and
ignorance when we remember we are the
world for whom Christ died the cross
that lead us the face where I think is
the greatest danger the church faces I
lack of active participation in the
problems that plain people we've allowed
our prejudices our habits our doctrines
our superstitions to separate us from
the real reason for the cross show we
are the ones for whom Christ died he
came to save the whole world and put no
condition and all except believe he
didn't say you had to be good he didn't
say you had to live the way folks say
you ought to live
he said just believe because your belief
in him will cause you to do other things
he came to save the whole world
our commitment ought to be his concern
when we moved from spectator to
participate we will discover that the
low is life because more of us are
carrying the love and then young the
church community will find continue see
contentment y'all deals with your
outlook on life and outlook on life that
you have ought to have four dimensions
they ought to be depth to it height to
it length and breadth to it and for us
as believers we must have God's outlook
we cannot look down on anyone because
God does not look down on anyone God
says if you just
need to be in your life where I am
supposed to be
I will stretch you in places you never
thought you could be stretched and I
I'll use you in ways you never thought
you could be you we got you as the
church move from spectator to
participate look here
Jesus revelation of God is the
revelation we ought to know the charge
Jesus didn't look down on anybody he
came to save all people of all races he
he's not a black Jesus not a white jeans
it's not not the Lord Jesus or Hispanic
Jesus he came to save all people in all
conditions and under all circumstances
the Bible is clear tells us who are
believers that if we will lift him up to
many of us think we can solve the
situations in our world that we have a
cure that is not centered in this book
but can i really help you up the world
it's gonna really be cured then we have
to carry the cross of Christ before this
world in a way that lets them know I am
there for you not as a spectator but as
an a participant the inclusive love of
Jesus gives new breath to our vision and
concern we are so adept at building
fences with shut people out that we fail
to realize that Jesus has no use for
fences notice Jesus as brilliant as he
was 12 years old in the temple
confounding the doctors and the Lord is
Jesus as powerful as he was healing the
sick and giving sight to the blind and
giving death into ears
Jesus as as great as he was never
dismissed anybody who had a knee when
you begin to think about this it makes
you change your whole perspective on
your attitude
Christian what happens with the person
with HIV comes into your church how do
you respond to the alcoholic that walks
through your church doors how do you
treat that young lady who comes in with
a child out of wedlock and the question
becomes not what would Jesus do because
the Bible already tells you what Jesus
did and so you ought not be walking
around with a WWJD what would no we
ought to know what Jesus did he was God
for them because Jesus saying I'm not
gonna be expecting I came to be a
participant
they never resolved mankind's treatment
at the hands of men it's not the king of
faith in a kind of we made God the
scapegoat for our own fears and so we
use when I call the guard card whenever
it's something we don't understand we'll
say well you know God doesn't agree with
that let me really help you God places
things in the life of humanity to see
how we're gonna act and how we're gonna
respond he wants to see if you're gonna
act out your faith or if you're gonna
sit on the side of the road and judge as
folk go by he wants to see how you gonna
treat individuals as they journey
through what they have to go through
there's some folk in here this afternoon
who know that if it had not been for the
Lord on your side
when you were going through whatever it
was you were going through you would not
be hit content
the reason the believer who participates
can stand with power and authority is
because they're confident and content
and they know that this God that we
serve once Lord from us this man showing
up the see what was going on got pulled
out of the crime and had to participate
in this run he didn't go there to get
his name perpetually remember he just
was in the crime but they pulled him out
of the crowd and now today over 2,000
years later people still call his name
because he was pulled out of the crime
but what happens when we get the concern
we need and the compassion we need and
the commitment that we need and come to
the contentment that we need then we
will have the Cure we need and see the
cure the cure the cure is never gonna be
and what we think can be done in a
test-tube because you can stop the virus
and the person still be infected by the
stigma that was placed on what are we
gonna do for the people who have been
cured and heal but yet the stigma of the
disease still rests in their memory and
show the church the church if we are
going to be what God would have us to be
has got to move from being spectators to
participants
look here when we get out of this field
of theology and began to understand in a
real way I can't study God because God
is not studying
he's beyond all the study you can do
because what you think you know what
God's gonna do God shows up and does
something else when you think you got
God figured out God will show you
something that you never thought you
would see how often how do we ask the
community of people who claim to have
this faith waste the energy and resource
arguing over stuff that does not matter
stuff that keeps us spectators and
stellar participants who cares if you
speak in tongues enough who cares if you
shout or not who cares if you go to
church on Saturday on Friday night all
the Sun okay these things keep the
church from being the powerful force in
the community but let me help you
whenever things get real bad it's
interesting that's the place folk got to
come back to it's interesting because
God has given to us the charge and the
mandate to do the things in the
community that are needful for the Cure
we understand Jesus was the first social
gospel leader long long long long before
theologians came up with a social gospel
Jesus Jesus Jesus already had
perpetuated our social gospel he says I
got to reshape my argument so I can
reshape the world religion fails you
and that's our problem we are so caught
up in religion that we forget what the
Word of God is really saying religion
fails but righteousness works the Bible
doesn't talk about only the religious
shell sigue because the religious always
been here
before Jesus got here religious hope we
but but after Jesus came for begin to
understand being religious is not enough
I got to move from spectator to
participants look what happens when you
move the church for spectator to
participate you will understand what
this man learned on that road when they
pulled him out the crowd that I myself
am carrying this cross now but what did
Jesus say that we who are left must deny
ourselves take up our cross daily and
follow him how many of you have left
your cross by the road for somebody else
to care how many of you are waiting to
someone else to do what God has called
you to do how many of us has spent our
lives being spectators and not
participate I'll never get a few years
ago in Hartford Connecticut we reformed
for teenagers who were involved in drugs
and who were involved in sexual
promiscuity and who were involved in
gang violence we have about 17 hundred
young people in that room that day we've
got up with a great panel of folk and
experts who talked about all the things
that should be done then dr. Wallace
they asked for questions like you have
all day today young lady
waited while anyone asked any questions
then she walked to the microphone she
says I have a question she says I came
here today because I'm not pregnant
I'm not on drugs I'm not part of the
gang I'm a straight-a student I'm not
gonna be able to go to college because
all of the programs are designed for
fuku than already messed up and I sat
down on that panel that did and listened
to her as she told her story I'm mother
and father died a grandmother was ill be
able to afford to send her to college
and she says if I go out and do
something wrong I can get help but
because I've decided to be right nothing
is open for me and I told us that young
lady you just fit in so I get to you
because the church has got to understand
that you just can't be expected you've
got to be actively participating in the
lives of individuals that young lady is
an attorney today because we took time
to move from spectator to participate
and I pray then when we leave this place
today that those who are sat in the
workshops and those who have been in
these seminars will leave they're
determined to stop being spectators and
become participants publishers
so the pastor Reverend dr. Washington
was kind enough to leave time for
questions and I want you to know that if
you connect what you heard right now is
what you heard earlier today which was
mr. Cruz saying that the nonprofit
church in particular the black church is
a resource that could really play a
vital role in national hiv/aids
formation but also in addressing other
health crises and epidemics and
specifically in terms of the hiv/aids
epidemic we have just heard the kind of
message that is specifically tailored to
all the other black churches across the
nation so this message is something that
will be up on university iTunes under
this conference so that we hope that
everyone here who knows of any church
black white egg church mosque who needs
to hear how can you tell her an hiv/aids
message that combines the particular
doctrines of your faith and a message
which is essentially no different from
what we heard from President Obama on
January 20 because this is an era of
responsibility so you see
it's about asking for credit questions
and getting people to talk in such a way
that you find out what is your frame of
reference so it just heard a message
given specifically for those who say oh
my I'm a Christian okay I believe in
Jesus Christ and so this is a perfect
example of how it's like the information
in this station in this world can be
tailored either you can adapt or total
or Haiti or India so that it is
culturally appropriate and so for
African Americans okay who believe in
Jesus Christ who said yes I want to be
like Simon I you can call me out the
crowd
I will help Jesus to carry the cross but
that brief this is an ideal model of the
kind of message that any pastor to the
deck and it could hopefully inspire
those in mosques and synagogues and
other places is in temple to say ah and
this air of responsibility I need to go
to the text it
my people will respond to and tell a
message of essentially a call to action
reach so we are so grateful that of the
Reverend dr. Washington is allowing us
to have something that is now to be
globally accessible and takes away from
it particular culture group and excuse
as to why they couldn't tell in the best
because he showed us how you can tailor
a costly perfect message to inspire
people to respond to the call to action
to share responsibilities let's give him
another
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes tc
Columbia edu